yeah they will face nick pavetta start
number 20 for pavetta he earned his
eighth win as last time out that was
against the blue jays back in buffalo
he's got good numbers uh he leads the
red sox starters an opponent's batting
average
that's just 234 strikeouts 117 he leads
them in that he's averaging 10
strikeouts
per nine innings pitch he got that win
win number eight
last time against the blue chase but he
had to deal with a lot of base runners
if you remember that he gave up a season
high
11 hits in that game he also had a
couple of walks
blue jays beat him back in june right
here in this ballpark
when he gave up a career-high four home
runs to toronto so hoping for some more
of that tonight from the blue jays
offense
two down for bowl bushette who has been
hot playing a hard ground ball right
side diving stabbed
by chavis fires and cordero hill the bag
well done on both ends francie who's
long and lean
had to stretch to the right field side
to grab that throw
a very hard hit ball with the shed is
out yeah making his season debut tonight
start of the season on the injured list
if you remember that
right elbow impingement he remained
there until july
the sixth he was then optioned down to
buffalo
got into eight starts there look at
those numbers right there sparkling
numbers for hatch
while he was there you know he had some
times where he walked some batters but
then he really threw the ball well this
month his last two starts
20 home runs for martinez 8th in the
league and hitting at 300 even with 64
rbis there's a high fly ball to left
field back by the scoreboard
and this ball with guriel back he jumps
he can't get it it's off the wall
the intersection with a double is jd he
didn't get it
all but get it down near the end of the
bat however
jd martinez has his 28th double so he's
one behind his teammate xander bogarts
for the league lead as he hit a breaking
ball
here's rappy now 279 80 rbis one in
front of
guerrero for the legally 26 homers that
gets underneath
[Applause]
that wrist area ever since that slide so
he moves up
on the wild pitch and with two down a
man 90 feet away for raphael
fastball right down the middle and hatch
strikes out endeavors caught looking
good start for thomas hatch he gives up
a double but strikes out two no
score after an inning in sacks with his
second double off thomas hatch
madugo batting out of the six hole 272
nine home runs
shot into left center field of base hit
here comes renfro rounding third
greechik comes up
throwing and it sails all the way to the
backstop
down to second goes verdugo is rent fro
with a pop-up slide scores the game's
first run
one-nothing boston reaching had no
chance to get him and he really
airmailed that throw
it won't necessarily be an error because
roduko might have taken second on the
throw anyway
so the bases are loaded with nobody out
here's michael chavis
little bounty ball up the middle of the
shot they'll grab that go to first place
in time as the run comes in the score
now that's where go touch it all play
for that's actually two to nothing all
right
make some contact stay away from those
strikeouts and good things will happen
and here's the value of having vladie
guerrero hit in the two spot
he's batting with two on and nobody
happened that's in the left field
mcguire hits third and he is rounding
and coming in
and he will score on an rbi for vlad
guerrero
that's number 80 on the season and it
ties him with rafael devers atop the
baseball tally board
and just like that it's a one-run game
and here's marcus
wrecking ball hit into the outfit that's
going to get down for a base hit
springer got a good read he's coming
home the ball is cut off and just like
that
the game is tied good job by marcus
simeon he picks up rbi 62 and it does it
with a couple of strikes curve ball
and he stays back on it he's going to
pick up an rbi
single you mentioned the jump in the
read by
george springer at second base the last
person you look at when you're a runner
at second base you want to find out
where that center field is playing
you've already
looked to see where the shortstop is
playing but you check to see where that
center fielder's playing
blue jays shift their infield around to
the right for rafael devers
that one ripped out of the line that's
headed for the corner
she's gone rafael endeavors about face
his 27th hole
and the red sox back on top three to two
i guess he doesn't like trailing
guerrero
in that rbi race hunting for an inning
yeah this is quite a battle going on
fastball gonna be inside by about a
couple of inches and he just
lays the hammer on it line shot
homerun run two men down so he can
escape work around that lead off double
but still a tough out to get and young
bull buchet
swinging a drive get up get out of here
hit a rocket into the green monster
seats and the blue jays have the lead
that's his fourth home run against
boston this season
and he comes through once again 18th
home run of the season
for bo michelle franchi gunning for that
third hit a pair of singles tonight
there's a slider as popped up down the
left field line guerrielle
over near the fence reaches in and makes
the catch
good effort by curiel what a job by
lourdes goriel jr as he goes
into the stands and in spite of making
the catch and throwing the ball back
into play it appeared as if a fan just
really wanted to have the ball given to
her
he had the good concentration to keep
his eye on that ball had to deal with
the wall there's the netting on the left
so that didn't come into play
and then into the stands he goes with
third
we check all for three with a single in
the second inning swings and it's a pop
fly
on the infield tk calling the shortstop
is there and has it for the outfit
retires the side so they leave a runner
at third and after seven and a half
it is four three jays the first red sox
base runner since the fifth inning
and alex verdugo is coming up swinging
there's the drive hey high and deep
right center field back by the bullpen
and
it is gone two run homer alex perduko
red sox lead five to four can you
believe it
alex for dugo's tenth of the year and
the red sox come from behind again
leading going into the ninth last time
the red sox won consecutive games from
trailing in the eighth inning or later
was back in 2018 it was against the
yankees
and against the blue jays that would be
the case again here in 2021
swag popped up and a short right chamus
a renfrow
in chavis is there he's got it and the
red sox do it yet again they come from
behind
and they win the ball game